hey what's up guys this marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and in this one i'll be
showing you guys how to create a
professional email address uh that you
can use for emailing companies and for
media inquiries etc so let's get started
so a lot of people might be wondering
why exactly would you do tutorial on
creating an email address it's well
known that you can create a comcast
email or a gmail email but i think a lot
of companies find it appealing when
someone emails them requesting a product
to review from an email that's just
really simple and clean and professional
so here's a website that i found i'm
obviously not the first to discover this
but it's mkbhd at mail.com that is the
email address that i've used the site is
mail.com very simply so all you got to
do is sign up for a free email account
and you can create uh one of a number of
email accounts first you have to put in
a little bit of information about
yourself so your first name your last
name
choose your username and there are
actually a lot of usernames available so
i was
obviously able to get mkbhd very simple
very clean and obviously very appealing
for a company just to not see something
you know large and jumbled at
comcast.net or something and then you
get to go ahead and choose your domain
so you can choose something like at
mail.com
email.com
at usa.com
at dr.com
and a bunch of others there are a lot to
choose from and when i say a lot i mean
a lot you can choose from hobbies for
your location so you might be in the uk
and you can choose that or you can
choose
rome.comusa.com swissmail
as we scroll down here you can also
choose fun miscellaneous
uh at krs.comactivist.com
things like this
as we keep scrolling down there are as
you can tell a ton of names once you've
selected exactly what you want i just
chose at mail.com you can check to see
whether your username is available so
user stuff i don't know i'll hit check
and you'll see that it is available and
you can in fact use it and a lot of
these usernames are available so go
ahead and snag whatever email address
you'd like confirm all this information
and agree to the terms and service and
you are in and you have that email
address to use
now the thing is this actually is it's
really difficult to use an email client
such as msl thunderbird
to use your registered account for
mail.com for this reason they actually
provide an application or a desktop
application that allows you to check for
any new messages constantly
for your mail.com email address you can
right click go to account go to
preferences uh login and log out of your
email account for mail.com so it's
really simple desktop application sits
in your system tray and it works just
perfectly and starts at startup with
windows
so thanks for watching this hd tutorial
i hope you enjoy your professional email
address i will leave mine in the
description for business and media
inquiries as well as different questions
and various questions you guys can't
exactly phrase any youtube message
anyway thank you for watching this hd
tutorial and i hope it was helpful and
i'll talk to you guys in the next video
peace